[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 es uno de los más
grandes dramaturgos de la lengua
francesa
moyer nació hace cuatro siglos y sus
versos se han convertido hoy en culto
protegido del rey luis 14 molière es
celebrado cada junio por la ciudad
diversa y es donde debutó el festival se
llama el mes de molière y este año la
ciudad presenta más de 230 espectáculos
hoy y ya sale según kirk según vacila
cos y louis aragon nos cuentan más
[Música]
una comedia burlesca un poco de intriga
y su mirada perspicaz sobre las
costumbres de su tiempo
los enredos de escapa es una de las
obras más populares de molière y esta
representación forma parte del mes de
molière aquí en versalles un evento
anual para celebrar el legado del
escritor y dramaturgo
el sonido
y no le acojan con ello los vecinos y se
molía para un actor creo que es
infinitamente rico en términos de
creación de personajes realmente creo
que es el autor que más composición
permite es algo que realmente me gusta
la totalidad de su obra el campo de
posibilidades en términos de composición
es simplemente infinito contando
composiciones est aun sin igual esta
comedia en tres actos se representa en
las caballerizas del rey a pocos metros
del palacio de versalles para el
director y actor emanuel bsn o molière
sigue siendo hoy una poderosa fuente de
inspiración
hay una genialidad creo en la alianza
entre el lenguaje y la comedia que hace
que no haya sido igualada y que muchos
sigan utilizando su forma de escribir
para dar en el clavo
no sé cómo es posible que una obra
escrita en 1671 parezca tan moderna hoy
en día y que se pueda apropiar de ella
con tanta facilidad y libertad es como
si nos hubieran dejado una materia prima
maravillosa de la que aún hoy podemos
apropiarnos y eso es bastante raro
ya sea cerrar
[Música]
la ciudad de versalles celebra este año
la edición número 26 del mes de molière
una oportunidad para recordar que el
dramaturgo fue un invitado muy apreciado
en la corte de luis 14
sin duda molière era respetado por el
rey que reconocía su talento
comentó molière era al mismo tiempo una
persona muy impertinente y sabemos que
se permitía ciertas cosas gracias a su
condición de protegido del rey pero se
permitió a través de sus obras ser
bastante crítico con la iglesia que era
un poder esencial en el siglo 17 también
con ciertos nobles como puede ser cuando
aunque molière abandonó definitivamente
los escenarios en 1673 sigue reinando en
el arte dramático el literario en
versalles su aura es más brillante que
nunca como lo muestra esta escultura
inaugurada al comienzo del mes de
molière un homenaje de bronce al hombre
que hizo reír al rey sol las obras de
mujer en su época generaron controversia
y la problemática de los límites del
arte sigue siendo muy actuales lo que
muestra la edición número 15 del
festival de arte contemporáneo
en alemania ya se veía afectada por una
polémica en torno a la selección de
artistas palestinos críticos con la
política israelí y el evento decidió
finalmente ocultar un gran lienzo
titulado people sastres la justicia del
pueblo calificado como antisemita del
colectivo indonesio tarín país los
artistas respondieron que el mural fue
creado en 2002 para criticar el sistema
explotador y capitalista y la violencia
militar de indonesia pero las
asociaciones judías siguen pidiendo que
se retire el mural documento 15 es la
mayor exposición de arte contemporáneo
del mundo con la bienal de venecia del
lado de españa otras imágenes
impresionaron pero esta vez en el buen
sentido es el maravilloso desfile de joe
en sevilla que rinde homenaje al baile
al cine y a la moda del país en su
colección cruz era de 2023 y es la
primera vez que un evento de moda de
esta escala se celebra en español
[Música]
en méxico también la moda se inspira en
las tradiciones pero en las tradiciones
culinarias en este singular desfile de
ropa que los estudiantes de la
universidad del claustro de sor juana
crearon a partir de alimentos utilizaron
ingredientes típicos como el chile el
cacao los frutos secos y el caramelo
para reconocer y visibilizar a las
tribus urbanas más comunes en mexico
como lo hacemos los solos o los góticos
ellos también saben mezclar los géneros
y los estilos con habilidad son los
artistas musicales que les recomendamos
esta semana empezando en francia por la
canción les mataría déjame decirte la
nueva colaboración que surgió gracias a
gnu linux un proyecto que asociaba a
varios artistas que nunca han
colaboraron juntos esta vez son los
versos del rapero ansa que se ajustan
perfectamente a ritmo afro love the
times
y en eeuu el rapero
logró integrar su estilo al nuevo tema
de john legend entre música pop funk y
sol anunciando el octavo álbum del
cantante
[Música]
nos despedimos con un tercer dúo y
cónico el rapero trueno y la cantante
nati pelusso estrenaron un videoclip
para su tema argentina que muestra otra
cara del país en un tempo hip hop pero
con un aire de tango en el fondo gracias
por su confianza y cuídense
muerte san martín en el salón del show
no fuese hasta argentina está caminando
a mi lado pekín noticia
los golpes de la vida ya me tienen
preparado le dispara todo
los machos de latinas
caminando
[Música]